لقد كنت تتنقل بين
واشنطن وعمان ، يجب أن
يقال منذ أسابيع
تتحدث إلى إدارة بايدن
وتحذرهم مما كان من المحتمل أن يأتي
هذه الإدارة التي تقول حتى الآن على
الأقل إنها
ستدعم وقف إطلاق النار لكن إدارة بايدن
ستفعل ذلك.  لا تطلبوا أحداً لماذا لا يطالبون أحداً لماذا لا يطالبون
بوقف إطلاق النار ما هو
فهمك للموقف في
واشنطن في هذه المرحلة ،
لقد كنا نعمل عن كثب
مع واشنطن أه
لمعالجة أه هذا الوضع الخطير للغاية
حتى من قبل  العاشر من مايو
عندما
أه الصراع أه أخذ
منحى أسوأ
أه كنا نتحدث مع الأمريكيين
عن ضرورة كبح
الإجراءات الإسرائيلية المسببة
لهذا الصراع أه الأمريكيون مشغولون
أه نحن في مباحثات معهم
هم  أرسلت بعض رسائل أه جيدة جدًا
أه تجاه أه حاجة
إسرائيل لاحترام
أه أه الوضع التاريخي الراهن في
المقدسات وفي القدس
لتوقف المستوطنات من أجل أه  لن تحدث عمليات
إخلاء أهالي
الشيخ جراح ، لذا فنحن نتعامل
معهم ، فنحن نعمل
معهم في كل ذلك ،
كما تعمل مصر جاهدة للغاية
لمحاولة الحصول على وقف لإطلاق النار اليوم ، عقد جلالته
اجتماعًا مشتركًا مع
الرئيس ماكرون والرئيس.  السيسي
وتحدث لاحقًا
مع ميركل ، لقد كنت على اتصال مع
الوزيرة بلينكين
، نحاول جميعًا وضع حد
لهذا العدوان لهذا التصعيد
ولكن مرة أخرى نفهم أن
إسرائيل هي التي لا تزال تقول
لا  وقف إطلاق النار ونحن بحاجة إلى الاستمرار
في التوصل
إلى هذا المطلب بوقف إطلاق النار
وعلينا أن ننظر مرة أخرى أه
بيكي لماذا نحن
هنا وأعتقد أن الاستنتاج الذي
يجب أن نتوصل إليه جميعًا
هو أن  الوضع الراهن
لا يمكن تحمله
أه التصعيد الحالي
كشف عبثية
الافتراضات الزائفة للماضي بأنك
تستطيع القفز فوق القضية الفلسطينية
وتهميش القضية الفلسطينية ويكون
لديك
وأعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى النظر إلى
التصعيد الحالي من منظور أوسع
سبب وجودنا هنا.
منازلهم ثم التصعيد والتعدي على
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وحذرنا
حينها من التوقف لان هذا
يدفع المنطقة كلها نحو
تصعيد لا يريد احد منا رسائلنا
ولم يسمع تحذيرنا لم يسمع.  إلى ما وراء
السبب المباشر أعتقد أن ما
يحدث يتحدث عن حقيقة
أن مستوى الإحباط من
غياب الأفق السياسي
ترسيخ الاحتلال
أه زينة
حل الدولتين من
قبل بعض السياسيين الإسرائيليين
الطريق الوحيد للأمام
ساهم جميعًا في خلق
البيئة
التي أدت إلى الانفجار الحالي ،
فمن مصلحتنا جميعًا التوقف عن
فرض  ارجع إلى صراع القواعد
وتقبل أن
الاحتلال هو أصل كل الشرور إذا
أردنا أن نحقق السلام والاستقرار
علينا أن نوقف الاحتلال علينا
أن نحترم
المكانة المقدسة للأماكن المقدسة في القدس علينا أن
نحترمها.  حقوق الإنسان للفلسطينيين
في الحرية في الكرامة وإقامة الدولة ،
هذا هو المكان الذي
تكمن فيه القضية في أن هذه هي الحقيقة التي
يجب على الجميع إدراكها ،
لذلك نحن الآن بحاجة إلى التركيز على شيئين ،
أحدهما إيقاف العدوان وإيقاف
الاستفزازات.
تأكد من أننا وصلنا إلى وقف إطلاق النار
تأكد من أننا نساعد الأشخاص الذين
يعانون
بشدة وقد تحملوا معاناة أكثر من أي
شخص
في العالم وثانيًا أه نطلق على
هذا الزوج من الأشياء بأسمائها ويقبل ذلك
أه طالما  لديك احتلال
لن نحصل على سلام
ومسؤولية كل واحد منا هي
العمل معًا من أجل خلق آفاق
للسلام وإعادة الانخراط في المفاوضات
والمضي قدمًا نحو
حل الدولتين  التي من شأنها معالجة
الحقوق المشروعة
للجميع وتحقيق السلام الذي هو
حق للجميع في هذا الجزء
من العالم في نهاية المطاف